that's where we're happy to be joined
tonight by bacia under sargon she's the
deputy opinionator at newsweek she's
single-handedly responsible for making
that magazine worth reading once in a
while and so we're happy to have her
bocce thanks for joining us tonight um
no it's true i never thought i'd be
reading a newsweek piece until you took
over so thank you for that um
so so clearly they they've decided you
know the the hive has turned on the
queen um how does this play out do you
think
you know tucker first of all thank you
so much for having me and a big mazel
tov congratulations to you for being the
number one most watched show among
democrats uh you know it's such a
privilege to be here with you we get to
talk to both republicans and democrats
and that's very related to what we're
discussing here you know my view is that
the reason that the liberal media is
turning on president biden is because he
failed at the one thing they really
needed him to do which was to sustain
the fiction that the big divide in
america is political when as what you
know because you cover this every night
on your show the real divide is about
class and on a host of issues from covet
to crime to inflation to the role the
u.s should be playing in the war in
ukraine
you know working class and middle class
americans who are republicans and
democrats they just are not divided on
these issues they are divided from the
elites who claim to represent them but
there's that yawning gulf between the
liberal media the elites the democratic
party and where average americans of
both parties are at and i think they
thought president biden would help them
paper over that gap when what's happened
is he's come to embody it and so they're
distancing themselves from him to sort
of hide from their own failures tucker
i mean you ca it's so simple the formula
that you just
suggested is so obvious if you had a
president who was truly moderate truly
interested
in the lives of the people he
represented who cared about people
making 70 grand and not just people who
run amazon like you could you could win
every election and rule forever why
don't they do that
i mean it's such a great question i
think you know last night you talked
about monopolies and how you know
anybody who resists sort of threatens
the monopoly and threatens the power and
i think that the democrats and the
liberal elites in the media have gotten
a lot of power from consolidating around
you know the class that they share and
you see it even i think tucker on one
area where the president actually is
sort of representing where americans are
at which is on ukraine he's really
walked a fine line i think towards
supporting the ukrainians the way
americans want him to but not escalating
in the way that americans really don't
want him to and on that you know the
media beats him up the worst right
because he's threatening that elite
point of view that is so true and i i
think i mean what do i know i'm not in
touch with biden every day but just
watching him on tv he did not his first
instinct was not to escalate i don't
think he wanted a war with russia and it
really felt like he was suborned by the
people around him to escalate beyond
what most americans want they want to
support ukraine they don't want a hot
war with russia fair
yeah
exactly exactly yeah and i think that
you know he is trying his best to resist
pressure from both parties by the way by
the from the elites in both parties
although of course not from this show
because you tell it like it is tucker
well i appreciate that yeah no it's
certainly the republican party pushing
him it's total craziness but baci thanks
so much for coming on and what you're
doing newsweek appreciate it thank you
so much thank you subscribe to the fox
news youtube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
tucker carlson tonight